And now, for you, Scoutmaster.
Here we are, we're at camp. It's the first night at summer camp.
Seeing patrolers kind of looking around, checking out to make sure everybody's okay,
and the scouts are doing well, and he notices one of the guys is having a little trouble walking
and wondering if maybe he hurt himself or something like that.
The guy goes over and talks to him and says, hey, I noticed that you, did you hurt your foot or something?
And the boy says, oh, no, no, no, I'm fine.
But it looks like you're having trouble walking.
He says, well, it's kind of hard to wear all these socks at first, but I'll get used to it.
And the senior patrol leader says, what do you mean wear all these socks?
He says, well, the list of equipment for summer camp said we needed seven pairs of socks.
And the senior patrol leader answered him and said, well, yeah, but you're not supposed to wear them all at once.
And the scout said, well, what my plan is, is if I put on all seven pairs, I'll just take one pair off every day,
and that way I won't have to worry about changing my socks.
Yeah.
It's amazing the way they think, isn't it?
But what an efficient plan.
Hey, this is podcast number 22.
Hey.
Hi.
Recruiting is definitely the hardest part of a scoutmaster's job and the one I was least prepared for.
There's just not much training in the BSA for it, as if no one has figured it out.
I think you might be right there.
I asked, where do I find recruits?
The only answer was Weeblos.
And then I asked, can I go to their meeting and make a pitch for our troop?
And I was answered, all the Weeblos have crossed over by now.
So yeah, it's kind of like duck hunting.
If you're not there when the ducks are migrating, forget about it, right?
This is a daunting task for a troop of 10 scouts and three adults.
I have talked to boys who did not have a scouting background from church, youth groups, and sports teams
and have not seen any new scouts from these activities.
I would like to talk to the parents and explain how our program can help their children.
My question is, how do I get in front of them?
Well, Alan, I'm not too sure you want to be in front of them.
Because one of the points I'm trying to make about recruiting and the variable successes
that you have with different recruiting methods is that the wholesale methods don't seem to work real well.
And again, I don't have this all figured out, but I'm just going off the top of my head.
The wholesale methods, you talking in front of groups, don't seem to work too well.
You want retail.
Retail method, which is one-on-one, anytime that you possibly can.
So this is what I'm going to suggest to you.
How about this?
You have 10 scouts in the troop.
You say you have three leaders, but with 10 scouts, you have somewhere between 10 and 20 adults
who are some way associated with the troop.
That includes the scouts' parents.
Now, can you motivate them to each talk to, you know, 5 or 10 other families within a given period of time about scouting?
If you do that, well, there's between 50 and 100 families, you know, 50 and 100 boys that you've approached about scouting.
I can almost guarantee, I can't positively guarantee, but I can almost guarantee if you do those numbers,
you're going to get somewhere between 2 to 10 scouts out of it.
If you get 10, you have double drew numbers.
If you get 2, that's 2 more than you've got now.
I mean, it's kind of hard work.
Naturally, the best thing to have is what I'm sure you already have,
which is an engaging, interesting, and wonderful program that advertises itself and draws boys in like a magnet.
But if you can motivate the folks to do that, and how would you do that?
Well, make up an invitation that has a series of dates on it.
Set aside one troop meeting every month as an open house meeting.
You don't have to change the program radically or anything like that.
Just, you know, note in your head that it's an open house,
and you're going to spend some time talking to whatever parents show up.
And make that an invitation.
Give it to all the parents in the troop.
You know, give them 10 copies apiece or whatever and say,
hey, this is the way we're going to build our troop up.
It's going to be great.
Go ahead and give these to 10 families with a scout age boy
and encourage them to come around to one of our open houses.
And you'll have, sometimes you'll have an open house and nobody will show up.
You'll have an open house and two people will show up.
And it will be alternatively encouraging and discouraging.
But that's basically the way of the world with this.
I would really like to hear from any of you listening out there about effective recruiting methods.
Maybe events or plans that you've tried that have worked out real well so we can share them with everybody else.
Well, moving along.
Today's podcast is a special about summer camp.
And in Scout Mastership, in seven minutes or less,
we're going to be talking about how to have a good week at summer camp as scout leaders.
And then in the second part of the show, we're going to talk a little bit about homesickness.
Homesickness.
It's a real thing.
And it's something to deal with.
We got a full slate.
So let's get started, shall we?
Scout Mastership in seven minutes or less.
So if you're fortunate enough to be able to spend a week at summer camp as a Scout Master,
I want to give you a few ideas and reflections as a former camp director.
And I've got to tell you something.
Most of the difficulties we encountered were not caused by Scouts.
A lot of times where we ran into problems was with the leaders that the Scouts brought along with them.
I want to acknowledge something very important, especially with the things that we're going to talk about here about camp.
I'm no perfect guy.
I've been around long enough to see a few things and to acknowledge a few things, especially about myself.
So when I'm giving you this advice and these reflections,
it's not about me talking down to anybody or being whiny and complaining about things.
You know, some of you have told me that these things help.
So I'm going to keep after it.
The first thing that I'll suggest, don't overdo it.
Personally, don't overdo it.
And don't make yourself into a time bomb.
Listen, if you get hot and tired and hungry and thirsty,
get cool and rested and fed and hydrated.
I tend to be really cranky if I don't look after myself.
And as the years go by, you know, I tend to get crankier a lot easier.
So years of observation prove that, you know, not only myself,
but some of my fellow leaders can have the same problem.
So don't wear yourself to a frazzle.
You know, look after yourself.
And in doing that, you'll be looking after the interests of your scouts
because you won't be a cranky, mean monster to them.
I've done it.
So, you know, watch out for that one.
Camp staff members are totally dedicated to making your stay worthwhile.
Believe it or not.
Younger staffers are learning at the same rate as your scouts.
And you need to be considerate and supportive of them.
Don't berate, criticize, or argue, or yell at a staff member or a youth leader
or a fellow adult leader in the presence of scouts,
no matter how much you think they might deserve it.
A quiet talk at an appropriate distance will usually solve the problem.
And the problem could turn out to be yours.
Don't pull rank while you're at camp.
Do you know what I'm saying?
You're a scoutmaster.
You're not a general or an admiral.
So there really isn't any rank to pull.
Right?
You know, most people instantly respect your position.
Members of staff are told to respect your position.
Don't make a big deal out of it.
Don't ask for special privileges or try to impress staff members
with your own sense of self-importance.
I've been there before.
It's ugly.
Join in the program and encourage your scouts to do so,
even if the program, in your humble opinion, isn't all that good.
Now, I know, you know, maybe you are a scout troop that goes back to the same camp year after year.
That's my troop.
We've been going to the same camp for probably, I would guess,
since the troop was founded 65 years ago.
Or maybe you're a visiting troop that circulates amongst different camps.
You know, both are great options.
I don't have an opinion as to which one is better.
But you're going to circulate through a camp or you're going to go back to your camp.
And there's going to be one of those summers that's going to come along
where it just seems like things are a little lackluster
and they're not doing things as well as they did last year or at the other camp.
And, okay, so you recognize that and then you live with it
and you say that you're going to go ahead and join in whatever program there is
and make the best of it because a lively audience does more than anything
to enliven and energize a camp staff.
So when you get happy and involved, you'll see a commensurate response from the staff.
You know, participate in all the ceremonies and traditions and practices of the camp,
even if they're unfamiliar to you.
Camps and camp staffs are proud of their traditions.
Imposing our way of doing things on the program as a scout leader
is as rude as imposing your way of doing things in somebody else's home.
I mean, to a certain extent, you're a guest at your camp
and the staff is working hard to do things for you
and it's a good idea to play along with them.
Carefully monitor any inner troop rivalries that may develop.
Now, as I said, we've been going back to the same camp for ages
and there are troops that show up there at the same time
and over time, sometimes a little rivalry can develop
and that can be healthy, but it also can be an unhealthy thing
to have happen during a week at camp.
Remember, scout age boys are hyper-competitive
and they often need to be reminded about fairness and courtesy and sportsmanship.
So set the tone of gentlemanly competition
and then require it of your scouts.
Give your youth leaders all the responsibility for success that week.
See that they understand what needs to be done and how and why
and then observe from a comfortable distance.
Check in with them every evening, ask lots of questions
and only put your oar in when it's asked
or, you know, it's a matter of safety or propriety.
Be proud of your scouts.
Encourage them.
Congratulate them.
Admire them.
Don't try to be one of them
because you're not
and you won't be.
When the rare opportunity to join at the boy level presents itself,
when you get invited to do that,
jump in and have fun.
But don't interfere with their fun.
What is a successful week at camp?
That's largely for the troop to plan.
Yeah, the staff is there planning programs and things like that,
but you also have to be thinking.
I would tell you that a week at camp
is an unparalleled opportunity to encourage growth in your patrols.
Encourage them to more esprit de corps,
to more independent functioning.
You place that responsibility on the patrol leaders.
They should, they should,
each patrol should sleep and eat and clean and work and play as a team.
Now, if your camp doesn't incentivize patrol excellence
with an award of some kind,
you can initiate one yourself or you can even add to it.
You know, inspire a little friendly, gentlemanly competition amongst the troop.
It's also a fantastic opportunity to train your leaders.
You can capitalize on the week as on-the-job training for your youth leaders.
The difference between on-the-job training
and a more formal training thing
is that the scouts are exercising leadership skills in actual time
and in an actual situation instead of an artificial one.
Don't have instructional sessions that last a long time.
Here's what you do.
You get the guys together.
You give them five minutes on what's going to happen next,
the actions that they're going to need to take,
the plans that they're going to need to do,
and then let them go out and do it.
Then later on, get them back together for another five minutes,
five, F-I-V-E, not 10, not 15, not 20,
another five minutes,
and say, how did it go?
What was unexpected that you encountered?
How did everybody perform?
And what can you improve on?
And if you make a habit of that,
and you do that once a day for the week,
you're going to initiate a way of leadership training
that is in that coaching mentoring model that we all want.
How about advancement?
Frankly, I wish my scouts were more interested
in looking under rocks and climbing trees and going fishing
than they were in sitting through merit badge sessions.
Nonetheless, they really like to earn merit badges,
and each scout should set an advancement goal for the week
with the assistance of their patrol leader.
That's a good way to prepare for camp.
There's more experiences to have at camp
than just working on the merit badge system.
So there's some ideas,
just some general ideas to throw out there
to aid you in planning for camp
and having a good experience once you get there.
He's my favorite all-time Boy Scout.
You're my favorite all-time Boy Scout.
You were always on the beat, boy, beat, boy.
Yeah, you were always on the beat, boy, beat, boy.
I'm hanging in the street, boy, street, boy.
He was dancing to the beat, boy, beat, boy.
Yeah, you're my favorite all-time Boy Scout.
You're my favorite all-time Boy Scout.
He's my favorite all-time Boy Scout.
Night falls on our first day at summer camp
after we've checked in,
after we've done our swim test,
we've gone to retreat,
we've gone to dinner,
we've gone to the big opening campfire.
I'm sitting at my picnic table.
The Patrol Leaders' Council is meeting.
And as we're meeting,
at the outer perimeter of the lantern light
from our table,
I see a first-year Scout.
He doesn't quite come into the light.
He's just kind of orbiting out there.
He looks at us every once in a while,
kind of wistfully.
I know exactly why he's there.
He and his brethren have always been there.
For 20-plus years, they've been there.
He's a miniature, modern-day Odysseus
in the throes of some heroic ennui.
He is my homesick Scout.
Now, homesickness is very real.
It can be light and passing,
or it can be very dark and difficult.
A lot of people,
when they're separated from familiar surroundings
or their family for an extended period of time,
can become homesick.
They can have a sense of dread or helplessness.
They can be depressed.
They can be sad.
They can be frustrated.
They can be angry.
Or they can just feel kind of hopeless.
Extreme cases
even cause physical symptoms
like stomach pain and indigestion
and headaches and nausea and tears.
You have to understand homesickness
as a Scoutmaster.
It's relatively easy
to cure the vast majority of cases.
It's a very real problem,
and we shouldn't trivialize it.
I have to admit
that I've been guilty
of being less than sensitive
in handling homesickness in the past,
so let me share
some successful strategies with you.
To alleviate homesickness
from the get-go,
making sure that parents understand
your expectations for camp
can be very helpful.
Here's a sample
of what we put
into the materials
that we distribute
to our families
before summer camp.
We say this.
Parents are expected
to support their Scout's commitment
to spend a full week at camp.
There is a full schedule
of shared responsibilities
that begins on the Sunday we arrive
and continues unbroken
until we leave a week later.
If a Scout must arrive late,
leave early,
or spend time out of camp
during the week,
please let us know
as early as possible
so corresponding arrangements
can be made.
That being said,
arriving late,
leaving early,
or spending time away
from camp during the week
is actively discouraged
as it tends to compromise
the experience
not only for the individual Scout,
but for the rest of his troop
and patrol.
A week of camp
is often the longest time
our first-year Scouts
have spent away
from home and family.
It's natural that some Scouts
find this experience
difficult to endure,
as do their parents.
Our experience
with hundreds of Scouts
and parents
of all temperaments
assures us
that they not only endure
but flourish
and return home
having gained a great deal
from the experience.
Now, what do the experts
recommend?
Because homesickness
is not limited to Scouts.
There is actually,
you know,
a reasonable amount
of homesickness
that happens
when people go away
to college
and it can be
kind of debilitating.
So, you know,
people study this
and people try
and alleviate
the problem
and counselors
work on this
quite a bit
even with adults.
So, here's
what they recommend.
Sometimes bringing
a couple of mementos
from home
such as, you know,
photos or something
like that
can serve as a
transitional object
that help relieve
uncomfortable feelings.
I've had boys
bring a little
stuffed animal
with them
and, you know,
we're on notice
as a troop
and as adults.
We don't make fun
of that.
We don't trivialize that.
If they need to bring
that little stuffed animal
or a photo
or something like that,
that's fine.
Now, you might
be grimacing right now
and saying,
gee, that seems
awfully namby-pamby
for a boy
who's 11 or 12 years old.
Well, if it helps
them get through,
I think it's useful.
It doesn't weaken them.
It doesn't, you know,
it doesn't impinge
on the experience
that they're having
at camp.
It helps them
move through
those uncomfortable
feelings of homesickness.
So, how do we treat it?
How do we treat
homesickness?
Well, talking is usually
a very strong way
of treating homesickness.
It involves,
since there are
feelings of dread
and helplessness involved
and they're
mostly baseless.
You know,
talking can often
make these,
that particular case
of homesickness
dissolve.
Staying active
and involved
is always important.
Homesick scouts
are often reluctant
to participate
in much of anything
because they're kind of
perseverating on the fact
that they're homesick.
So, we've got to
make every effort
to keep them active.
staying engaged
is also
a very important
cure to homesickness.
Lots of group activities
and shared responsibilities.
You don't want scouts
just to be off
in a corner.
Like I say,
perseverating on the fact
that I'm homesick
and I miss mom and dad
and I'd really rather
be home than be here.
They need to stay
with other guys
and they need to be involved
with other guys.
I often ask
an older scout
that has experienced
homesickness in the past
to go and engage
with a newer scout
who's feeling
a little homesick
and that usually
does the trick.
Writing or calling home.
Now, I used to think
that this was anathema.
I used to think
that this was the worst
thing that you could do
because once they called home
they would, you know,
arrange some way
of making their parents
feel so bad
that they would come
and pick them up.
They would go away
from camp
and we'd probably
never see them
in scouts again.
But writing or calling home
can be very helpful.
Actually, speaking to someone
is probably one of the
more helpful things
that can happen.
This is what I do.
Before we make any calls home,
I speak to parents first.
And the first words
out of my mouth is,
hey, you know,
this is Clark
and I'm down at camp
and everything is fine.
He's not hurt.
He's just feeling
a little lowgy
and I want you
to be able to talk to him
and encourage him
to stick this out
because, you know,
he's going to be just fine.
And parents can be
as worried as the boys
sometimes.
So I like to talk
to them first
before the scout
talks to them.
You know,
college counselors
and chaplains,
as I said,
report that there are
a lot of freshman students
that experience
homesickness
serious enough
to affect their studies.
And if scouts
can overcome
homesickness
during that week
at summer camp
at an earlier age,
they'll be better prepared
for those experiences.
So we mustn't
trivialize homesickness.
We mustn't
berate boys
for being homesick,
make them feel worse.
If we do a little counseling,
a little mentoring,
a little coaching,
it'll solve
the vast majority
of cases
in just a couple
of minutes
and everything
will be fine.
Well, thank you
for listening
to another edition
of the Scoutmaster podcast.
You can read
the Scoutmaster blog
at
scoutmaster.typepad.com
And you can follow us
at
Scoutmaster blog
on Facebook
and
Scoutmaster
CG
on Twitter.
Subscribe to the
Scoutmaster podcast
on iTunes
and feel free
to leave a comment
or review
or rating.
You can email me
Clark Green
with your comments
and questions
at
ClarkGreen
gmail.com
That's
C-L-A-R-K-E
G-R-E-E-N
at
gmail.com
The Scoutmaster blog
and the Scoutmaster podcast
are not
official publications
of the Boy Scouts
of America
nor are they
endorsed
or sponsored
by the Boy Scouts
of America.
Nah,
nope,
it's just me
talking into a microphone
trying to lend a hand
to Scout leaders
and maybe have a bit
of fun along the way.
Well,
we're off to summer camp
in what will seem
like an instant
but I hope you enjoy
your time at camp
this summer.
Always a lot of fun
and we're going to
we'll take off
here
after we've heard
from the founder
Sir Robert Baden-Powell.
Sir Robert,
what have you to say
to everyone?
Good luck to you
and good camping.
Why,
thank you,
Sir Robert.
Until next time.
next time.
gratitude
and
ăn
よ
şob
guitar solo